we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
i invite you yes you to call anytime if
you want to call it four in the morning
as many people do
go ahead and call it four in the morning
or call at a more normal time
here is a voicemail asking uh really a
pretty important question
about what will republicans do about
trump if trump loses
in november hey david i feel like we
don't talk enough about how if trump
loses he's going to be
tweeting from the sidelines constantly
and i'm serious your thoughts if you
think
his base will still hold him up as a god
if you think um
members of congress will um uh be
influenced by him or if they're just
gonna if they're eager to just
have an excuse to ignore him i'm curious
your thoughts thank you
i think it is ultimately going to depend
it's a good question if trump loses but
he just keeps tweeting tweeting tweeting
and he has a presence and he's on fox
news
what will actual elected republicans do
will they still sort of uh
give deference to trump and listen to
trump or will they
um denounce him i think it will likely
be neither i think the most likely
scenario is if donald trump loses and
ultimately he will go
he will resist it he will claim it's
rigged but ultimately he will go
my sense is yes donald trump will keep
tweeting yes donald trump will continue
to be interviewed
on maybe it'll be fox news maybe he'll
shift to oan maybe he will start his own
uh right wing network of some kind my
instinct is republicans will not widely
denounce
trump but they'll sort of pretend it
never happened remember how
uh george w bush was not a big part
at all of john mccain's 2008 campaign
because george w bush was very unpopular
and polarizing donald trump is 10 times
more than that
so my expectation would be that there
would be a lot of sort of pretending the
last four years didn't happen
if donald trump loses and i do not see
it as likely that trump
will shut up i think that he will
continue to use twitter and platforms
because he's narcissistic and he's
desperate for attention all the time
we have a great bonus show for you today
i will tell you and pat will tell you
what we have planned for our upcoming
staff vacation we are going to be on
vacation next week the show is not being
canceled
we are going to be back more powerfully
than ever probably with a million
youtube subscribers
after that vacation but we are taking
next week off
we will talk about what we're going to
do we will talk about this totally bogus
nomination trump received from a far
right norwegian politician for the nobel
peace prize
we will talk about the astrazeneca
vaccine trial being
paused and some people are making a way
bigger deal out of this than it actually
is so we're going to talk about that
and also very interesting news from the
field of
is it archaeology egyptian authorities
discovered 13 completely sealed
2500 year old coffins super interesting
news
we will talk about the implications and
much more
on today's bonus show how do you get
access to the bonus show it's easy
it's really really easy you go to
joinpakman.com
that's www.joinpakman.com
and you sign up that's it it takes under
a minute and you can use the coupon code
this is 2020 to save
66 off of your membership actually no
i'm sorry
this is 2020 saves you 40 percent it's
still good
if you want to save 66 the coupon code
is
2020 now 2020 now i will see you on the
bonus show